cet été la pratique du sport était au
centre des préoccupations de l'état et
des collectivités
comment occuper une jeunesse qui n'a pas
toujours la chance de partir en vacances
[Applaudissements]
pour aller à la rencontre des habitants
des quartiers
le club de rugby de tours a eu l'idée de
s'équiper d'un ministère gonflables
quand on arrive avec nos structures
gonflables et nos éducateurs pour
rentrer dans le terrain de rugby il ya
des fois des réticences ils ont pas trop
envie et à la fin de l'animation ils
veulent plus sortir et on est obligé de
les pousser un peu dehors parce qu'on
s'en va et ça c'est la preuve que ça
leur a plu pour finir en beauté cette
opération estivale la structure
gonflable a été montée au sein même du
stade tonnelet tout un symbole pour les
enfants c'est important pour eux d'être
sur un vrai stade de sport de rugby par
exemple ici on est au rugby c'est
important parce qu'ils vont se sentir
comme les autres c'est comme celle jouée
à l'athénée autres donc c'est vrai que
c'est intéressant et on remarque quand
même depuis ce matin il participe à tous
les ateliers
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu connais c'est le rugby
non j'en avais jamais fait mais j'aime
bien donc je vais à temps plein
d'activités qui tombe bien amusé ouais
c'est cool ça fait de l'accrobranche je
vous dis du foot du malawi
on a fait du buzz foot voilà donc l'été
qu'ovide il était assez top en fait
ouais un peu court mais c'est sans doute
le meilleur des compliments que pouvait
faire ses enfants à tous ces animateurs
grâce à eux 2020 fut un était presque
normale